extra dimensions i hope there is such a
thing as extra dimensions okay i plan to
talk about extra dimensions today and
the possibility that there could be
other dimensions beside the three we see
usually we only see three dimensions of
space there's one pointing in that
direction
one pointing straight forward
into you
and then one up down as well
and there's also time which we think is
another dimension here's three you can
see two fingers in the thumb they're
pointing in three directions those are
making up my three space dimensions that
we're all used to sometimes we call them
x y and z or z for our american friends
and
now the question is are there any more
okay now what a daft question that is
because you can see there's no more
space right
but in the world of mathematics you can
have as many as you like when you first
think about extra dimensions a lot of
films and things get mixed up with
parallel universes
universes which come completely
different where
there's space aliens who'd come through
and eat your grandmother or something
like that so in mathematics it's
perfectly viable you can do it you just
need to write down
um some extra coordinates you need to
think what to call them and write them
down and there you've got them
it turns out that in some of the models
of particle physics that try to unify
all the forces of nature in a particular
set of models called string theory
models
they only make sense
mathematically if you actually actually
have more than three dimensions you
allow there to be extra dimensions but
what we're actually talking about is
just a different direction i can point
in
so as opposed to just the usual three
directions there might be another one i
can't actually point in it or see it
but and one of the questions is why we
can't yet see them how can i have these
extra dimensions and yet still not see
them
well there are two possible ways that
people have thought of
the first is you hide them right hide
them make them really really small so
that actually you don't realize they're
there and
there's a way i think you might be able
to
think see this and and realize it makes
sense if you um
if you were to
have a
cable i've got a phone charger here
and the surface of it the surface of the
wires got two dimensions one long thin
dimension
it's an extended dimension
and one
short round dimension it's called a
compact dimension when you when the
cable's really close to you you can see
that the cable's got one dimension which
is the length of it but it's got another
dimension which is taking you around it
because it's a little circle right
now if i took this cable and just walked
all the way to the end of the building
or to the end of a garden and showed you
the cable again your eyes would no
longer be able to recognize that there
was this extra dimension all it would
see is this
thin line
and if you didn't know better that that
was a cable you'd say that's got one
dimension it's just got the length of
that line but then as you walked up to
it you'd go oh how stupid it actually
has a second dimension now effectively
what you're doing as you walk closer to
that extra dimension is you're you're
magnifying it it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
and the idea of in in in the world of
string theory in in these i
in the models of these extra dimensions
is it's it's a similar process the three
spatial dimensions we can we can see but
the extra dimensions are just wrapped up
into a very small ball so small that in
order to probe them you'd have to go to
very high energies that's the equivalent
of magnifying them
in the in the higher dimensional space
time there could be a four dimensional
sheet with three dimensions of space and
one dimension of time and we're stuck on
this and just can't leave it at all we
try but we can't even point in that
direction
and nothing we see around us can either
like light stuck in that one in that
three dimensions and
sound is and all the particles we
think we know about
but one particle might not or one force
might not called gravity and that could
go expand into the extra dimensions we
call it into the bulk away from our own
brain
and that could be used to explain why
gravity is so much weaker than other
forces why not say that the extra
dimensions are there but they just don't
interact with us
like in other words you know how do we
perceive things we perceive things with
light mainly
and that's the that's the way we see
events around us that's the way we see
the directions so if you have extra
dimensions in which light doesn't go
then you're not going to see it
and then the way you will test for these
extra dimensions is by having gravity
still working in these extra dimensions
well gravity is weak the entire earth
with all its particles is trying to pull
me down into
but
one little bench the electromagnetic
force in one bench can keep me up
against all of gravity
so gravity is a lot weaker
and that could be explained because the
other forces like the electromagnetic
force are stuck on our brain but gravity
is allowed to permeate into the other
dimensions and so you look for the
effects of gravity affecting objects
moving in these extra dimensions and
that's one that this type of these type
of models are called brain world models
oh i don't mean the brain in my head
that thinks i mean a shortening of the
word membrane which is like a sheet or
film well most people
approach extra dimensions with caution
they don't like the idea
they like the idea maybe of going to
other worlds and things but don't like
the idea of being able to point in
another way because it's
counter-intuitive we can't do it but
that doesn't mean it's not right
you're saying your wife's not a
scientist what does she think when you
talk to her about extra dimensions
and i think she sometimes wishes i'd go
there but
i think she finds it all fascinating
that just the
it because it
puts to one side the whole image of the
stereotypical image of a scientist that
doesn't have much of an imagination
how how big an imagination have you got
to have to be able to be prepared to
start thinking about a universe
which involves things that you can't yet
see
well string theory predicts that
there'll be nine dimensions of space and
one of time
so since we can already see three
dimensions of space and one of time that
leaves six to be coiled up very tightly